I welcome today's vote it's an emphatic  decision by this house that has declined  to back the Prime Minister's deal today  and clearly voted to stop a No Deal  crash out from the European Union the  Prime Minister must now comply with the  law he can no longer use the threat of a  No Deal crash out to blackmail members  to support his sellout deal labour is  not prepared to sell out the communities  that we represent we're not prepared to  sell out their future  and we believe that ultimately the  people must have the final say on brexit  which actually only the Labour Party is  offering today is a historic day for  Parliament because it said it will not  be blackmailed by a prime minister who  is apparently prepared once again to  defy a law passed by this Parliament I  invite him to think very carefully about  the remarks he just made about refusing  apparently to apply for the extension  which the EU number-two act requires him  to do